mr thiessen is honing his deadly
three-point precision on the basketball
court for one of his shots the height of
the ball in feet
as a function of horizontal distance as
a function
of horizontal distance in feet y of x so
here y is a function of x so the height
must be y because that's the thing that
is a function of something else so this
right over here is height
so our y-axis is going to represent
height
and it is a function of x so x must
represent horizontal distance because
height is a function of horizontal
distance so this right over here
is horizontal
horizontal distance
so this is horizontal
distance
now it's plotted below mr theoson is
standing at x equals zero
so he's standing right over here this is
mr thiessen so draw my best attempt to
draw a little stick figure version of mr
thiessen
that's not even an acceptable stick
figure right over there so this is this
is mr thiessen and he's standing at x
equals zero
and at x equals zero he is shooting a
basketball
he is shooting a basketball
and you see from the function right over
here that where the act where the where
the graph intersects the y-axis that
tells us that's that's essentially the
height of the ball when x is equal to
zero where it's where mr theoson is
standing and if we look at this this
looks like it's two four six feet six
feet high so that's really the initial
position of the ball when mr thiessen is
about to let go of it
then he lets go of it and the ball goes
in this parabolic trajectory
it increases increases increasing
increases it looks like it hits a
maximum point right around
right around there roughly that looks
like it's at about 16 feet
and then it starts to go down and right
over here and this looks like it's about
let's see 22 24 26 feet out
it looks like it hits something and
considering that something is 10 feet
high it's reasonable to assume that the
thing that it hits is the goal and
especially because he says that he has
or the question states that he has
deadly three-point precision we can
assume it's not crazy that he actually
makes the goal and so that's where it
goes into the net and then the net
forces the ball to go down at a much
steeper at a much steeper trajectory and
this is exactly of course 10 feet high
the height of the goal now let's see
which of these interpretations are
consistent with the interpretation that
we just did
the ball is released from mr theoson's
hand at a height of six feet well that
looks exactly right when x is equal to
zero the ball is six feet and not only
is that right but that is consid that is
the significance of the y-intercept of
this function the y-intercept is the
value of y the the height when x is
equal to zero so that is indeed the y
that is the significance of the
y-intercept look at let's look at these
other things mr thiessen is shooting the
basketball from 26 feet away
well that's right he's at x equals zero
the goal is at 26 feet away but that's
not the significance of that's not the
significance of the y-intercept that'd
be the significance of where we saw this
little point here that started to where
the ball dropped down at a more at a
steeper angle
the rim of the basketball hoop is 10
feet high once again that's true you can
look at it you can see it right over
there but that's not the significance of
the y-intercept
the maximum height the ball reaches is
16 feet well once again that is true but
that's the significance of this maximum
point on the curve that's not the
significance of the y-intercept so we'll
go with this first choice